[Music]
the fight for
[Applause]
[Music]
truth in a dark
world where truth is hard to
find
good men rise for justice they
bind amidst the evil eyes immoral people
say they'll Fight For Truth come what
may with hards of flame they take a firm
stand unyielding they raise their
hand they see through veils of Deceit
their mission clear they will never
retreat
in Shadows deep where Darkness breeds
they plant their seeds of noble
Deeds without fear they'll lead the
blind cuz walking in faith is the answer
for
mankind they follow the light they Forge
ahead their footsteps firm no fals would
[Music]
spread
and all the chaos Whispers loud they
speak the truth they make it proud they
want to set the captives free breaking
Satan's grip you see for lies May dance
and falsehood sway but good men's voices
won't betray with every word they break
suffocating chains igniting hope
wherever doubt remains their conviction
pure their purpose strong they battle
with God's armor all day long through
raging storms they'll navigate with
righteousness written on their
breastplate the spirit Burns through
them shining bright guiding lost souls
to the True
Light so let them rise these Warriors
bold their belt of Truth they will
uphold in a suffering world where many
deceive good men fight because their
hearts believe with love and light their
missions
clear to banish darkness and Conquer
fear their hearts Ablaze a fiery
might they battle demons day and
night with the shield of Faith they
stand
tall defeating evil one and all
all the battle is souls to save for
every human life a chance they crave
with God's mercy they heal deep scars
transforming lives like shooting
[Music]
stars no longer bound by Satan's
hold they find their true identity
their Spirits
bold through repentance they found
release and embraced a life of inner
peace
so let them
rise these Warriors
Brave and run the race until you meet
the
grave